the global game theory around bitcoin
has been something that has been
discussed for years now and yesterday we
hit a milestone moment russia is
officially considering accepting bitcoin
for their oil and natural gas of course
russia is under intense sanctions right
now from the united states and nato
allies and so naturally they're turning
looking for alternative payment options
what they specifically said in this
quote is that they are going to go to
those friendly countries like china or
turkey we have been proposing to china
for a long time to switch to settlements
and national currencies for rubles and
juan with turkey it will be lyra and
rubles but then here's the big part he
said you can also trade bitcoins that's
right russia is figuring out that maybe
they don't need to use u.s dollars it's
a problem for the united states but it's
not just using the chinese currency or
the turkish currency instead they're
also saying the apolitical money of
bitcoin could be an option now if we go
ahead and we look at this tweet from
nick carter he absolutely hammers the
point home odd how muted the reaction is
among the dollar global reserve forever
crowd russia is the literal number one
natural gas exporter worldwide if russia
starts to accept bitcoin for oil and
natural gas that's going to change that
global game theory and then if you look
at this tweet that i put out i said
every country is going to accept bitcoin
for two reasons they can have confidence
that no other country will debase it nor
can any other country seize it the
global game theory is real and that's
exactly what we're watching play out
here russia considering accepting
bitcoin for oil and natural gas is a
major major moment in the development
not only of bitcoin but also in the
deglobalization that is underway russia
is not playing around the united states
and nato allies put them in this
position
and now we're gonna have to figure out
how do we respond hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time